المنافس الابرز لترامب في انتخابات 2024
الرئاسيه وصف توجيها الاتهامات للرئيس
السابق بانه مناف للقيام الامريكيه وقال
انه لن يساعد في اي طلب لتسليم ترامب بعد
توجيه اتهام له ويشارك في وجهه نظره نائب
الرئيس الامريكي السابق الذي قال ان
الاتهامات ستصبح بالنسبه للشعب الامريكي
مثالا اخر على تجريم السياسه في البلاد
وانتقد اريك نجل دونالد ترامب الادعاء
العام ايضا واصفا القضيه بانها ذات دوافع
سياسيه وقال لابن الثاني لترامب على تويتر
هذا سوء تصرف قضائي ينتمي الى دول العالم
الثالث مضيفا انه استهداف انتهازي لخصم
سياسي في عام الحملات الانتخابيه
اما من جهه اخرى رئيسه مجلس النواب
الامريكي السابقا نانسي بيلوسي شددت على
ان هيئه المحلفين الكبرى تصرفت بناء على
الحقائق والقوانين مؤكده ان لا احد فوق
القانون
[موسيقى]